[Musique]
merci Stéphanie Taza d'être là avec nous
aujourd'hui à Château Morhange c'est pas
anodin c'est là où tout a commencé oui
tu ressens quand tu viens ici je t'avoue
que je me suis assise quand on s'est
positionné là j'ai un petit moment
d'émotion parce qu'à chaque fois ça me
rappelle ce fameux 9 avril 2009 mon
premier concert avec les premières mes
premières compositions en fait et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en 2023 et tu as
une nouvelle proposition une identité
musicale qui évolue qu'est-ce que tu
proposes alors en 2023 je propose un
voyage émotionnel en terre créole
c'est le titre Copacabana effectivement
annonce un prochain projet qui est
inspiré des terres créoles de la Réunion
bien sûr en particulier mais des terres
créoles en général
Maurice Cuba la Louisiane des terres on
parle créole les Caraïbes bien sûr
ça va
et toi tu vis la vida loca
dis-moi
dans tout ça
je l'imagine un côté de toi
[Musique]
pour moi je viens d'une terre d'une île
qui est internationale plus je voyage
plus je le ressens en fait j'éteins un
moment donné fasciné par cette idée que
des terres qui n'ont jamais communiqué
ensemble et autant de ressemblances je
veux parler aussi de partage pour écrire
les textes oui de tes futurs chansons
c'est important pour toi de travailler
avec la famille finalement ce qui est ce
qui nous entoure sur cette île ce qui a
de particulier avec cet album c'est que
je fais des ateliers de création
collective de chansons dans les
quartiers ou même avec le public avec
les femmes réunionnaises avec le projet
de l'album rose et c'est comme si même
aujourd'hui dans ce que je transmets
dans cet album il y a vraiment une
inspiration de toutes ces rencontres
autant je leur apporte je les accompagne
dans la création d'une chanson autant
eux m'inspirent parce qu'à chaque fois
c'est une histoire c'est un par c'est
c'est très riche en fait
[Musique]
le projet de l'album rose il est né sur
les réseaux sociaux ce sont les femmes
qui ont réagi en fait à mon appel et qui
ont proposé des thématiques 27 le top 4
des thématiques qui a été le plus
plébiscité par les femmes c'était la
charge mentale c'était la confiance en
soi être mère et rester femme
la pression de la société sur l'image ça
c'est ce qui revient finalement c'est
soit par rapport aux exigences de la
société dans ton parcours finalement il
y a une évolution de Stéphane étatsard
que quand on regarde derrière Koso dit
je dirais je suis fière d'avoir tenu bon
parce que le public se rend pas toujours
compte mais il y a eu des moments quand
même assez assez
pas évident en tout cas dans ce dans ce
parcours et je suis hyper contente
aujourd'hui de pouvoir d'avoir fait de
ces moments-là une force des
opportunités
[Musique]
tu me disais je fais quelque chose dont
je suis fière c'est important pour toi
oui alors je vais répondre à ta question
par une question je me suis posée
imagine ok 10 millions quels seraient
les projets que tu garderais si
l'argent n'était pas une question et là
je me dis c'est évident que je serai
dans ma carrière d'artiste là comme je
suis en train de faire c'est évident que
je ferai cet album l'album rose avec les
femmes et c'est évident que je serai
dans les quartiers c'est voilà je me
suis posé la question sincèrement et
pour une raison qui me dépasse
c'est mon moteur en fait tous les matins
pour me lever c'est comme si tu avais eu
une mission finalement et je me sens je
me sens une responsabilité
de transmettre par la musique et par la
voix merci beaucoup Stéphanie avec
plaisir